The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BOGDAN FEDELES: Hi,
I'm Dr. Bogdan Fedeles.
I'm a research associate
at MIT doing research
with Professor John Essigman.
I love biochemistry,
and I'm going
to help you solve
some problems today.
Let's work together through
question 5 or problem set 5.
This is an excellent question
about sugar biochemistry.
Specifically, we're
going to find out
how mannose an isomer
of glucose gets
to enter metabolism
by being converted
into fructose 6-phosphate.
Now mannose is a
common sugar that's
found in polysaccharides
and glycoproteins.
Here is the transformation that
converts mannose, shown here,
to mannose 6-phosphate
in first step.
And then in the second step,
to fructose 6-phosphate.
So our goal here will be
to figure out the mechanism
for these two transformations.
Let's take a look at the
first transformation.
We're converting mannose
to mannose 6-phosphate.
Now, as you guys have
encountered in biochemistry,
adding a phosphate group is
a ubiquitous transformation
and it's catalyzed by
proteins called kinases.
Now, kinases typically use
ATP, the energy currency
of the cell, as a
phosphate donor,
and transfer the
furthest most phosphate,
so-called gamma phosphate,
onto the substrate,
and leaving behind ADP.
A similar transformation
will be happening here
in part one of
the problem, where
mannose is going to be
converted to mannose 6-phosphate
by a kinase.
And the source of
the phosphate is
going to be ATP, which, in
the process, will yield ADP.
Now, in order for the kinase
to work, to react with ATP,
we also need magnesium.
So a salt of magnesium
with ATP is actually
essential for this
reaction to work.
Now, let's take a look
at the structure of ATP
to gain a little bit
more mechanistic insight.
As you know, ATP, or
adenosine triphosphate,
has these three
phosphate groups attached
to a 5-carbon
sugar called ribose
and a base, adenine, which we're
not going to draw out here.
Now, the phosphates
in ATP are typically
labeled alpha, the one closest
to the sugar, beta, and gamma.
Now, in order for
ATP to react, notice
these four negative
charges on the phosphates.
They need to be neutralized
in order for the molecule
to become reactive.
So this is what
magnesium is doing.
So at least early
on in the reaction,
magnesium is going to
neutralize two of these four
negative charges, while the
other two negative charges will
be neutralized by positively
charged amino acids
in the active site
of the kinase.
Once all the charges
are neutralized,
then the phosphorus
at the gamma position
will become available to be
attacked by a nucleophile.
In our case, the 6
hydroxyl of mannose.
So therefore, the reaction
proceeds as follows.
A base in the active site
will activate our hydroxyl,
which then can attack the gamma
position of the phosphate.
And then the phosphate gets
transferred to the mannose,
and it's going to
leave behind ADP.
Now, notice during this
reaction, magnesium,
which was coordinating two
of these negative charges,
will probably move to coordinate
these two charges or the newly
formed charge here in ADP.
And that would also
help stabilize the ADP
into the active
site of the kinase.
This mechanistic insight
basically answers part
one of the problem.
To talk about part
two of the problem,
we need to remember something
fundamental about sugar
biochemistry, namely that
5- and 6-carbon sugars
exist in equilibrium between a
linear form and cyclic forms.
Now, sugars that you've
encountered already,
like glucose and
fructose, they are
in equilibrium between
linear and cyclic forms.
So let's take a
look at them first.
This is glucose.
As you know, it's
an aldehyde that
has hydroxyl group on
all the other carbons
in this stereochemistry.
Now, this is a linear form of
glucose, and as an aldehyde,
it can react with
good nucleophiles,
like these hydroxyls, to
form cyclic hemiacetals.
If the reaction occurs with
a hydroxyl position four,
we're going to close a
five-membered ring hemiacetal,
which is shown here.
These kind of structures
are called furanoses.
So this is the glucofuranose.
Now if, instead, we
react with a 5-carbon,
then we're going to close
a six-membered ring, which
is called a pyranose.
This is glucopyranose.
Now, while the sugars
are in equilibrium
between the linear
and the cyclic forms,
the cyclic forms tend
to be predominant.
So in equilibrium, it will
be primarily 99% cyclic form
and only about 1% linear form.
Nevertheless, the presence
of the linear form
allows the sugars to
undergo some interesting
transformations, one of which we
are exploring in this question.
Similarly, here is fructose.
Fructose has the carbonyl
at the 2 position.
It's a keto group, and
then hydroxyl groups
on all the other carbons.
And just like glucose, it
can form cyclic hemiacetals.
So if the reaction happens
between the carbonyl
and the hydroxyl
at position 5, it's
going to close a
five-member ring shown here.
This is too a furanose.
This will be fructofuranose.
If the reaction happens with
the hydroxyl at the position 6,
then we're going to be closing
a six-member ring shown here.
This is fructopyranose.
Once again, just like for
glucose, the equilibrium,
it's strongly shifted
towards the cyclic forms.
Nevertheless, there is
enough of the linear form
to allow certain kind
of chemistry to happen.
Now, going back to solving
part two of our problem, that
is converting from
mannose 6-phosphate, which
is a sugar with a six-member
ring cyclic structure,
to fructose 6-phosphate,
a sugar with a five-member
ring cyclic structure.
Keeping in mind what
we just discussed,
that sugars, they're
in equilibrium
between these cyclic structures
and their linear structures,
linear forms, one
good place to start
to figure out how this
transformation will happen
is to write the linear forms
of the two molecules here.
Now, for the
mannose 6-phosphate,
we notice we have a hemiacetal
functionality at carbon
1, which is attached to
both the hydroxyl group
and another oxygen.
So this carbon
will form an aldehyde
in the linear form.
So let's write the linear
form of mannose 6-phosphate.
All right, so
notice at carbon 1,
we're going to have an aldehyde.
And then all the other carbons,
we have a 6-carbon chain.
Now, in terms of
mechanism, this is just
a reverse of the
hemiacetal formation,
and it's going to require
a base to deprotonate
the hydroxyl here in carbon 1.
And then we're going
to need to reprotonate
at the hydroxyl in position
5 to form this hydroxyl here.
Now, something to
keep in mind, though,
the way this enzyme
works is we don't really
know if the enzyme is catalyzing
this transformation as it's
written here, or the
enzyme is just binding
the linear form that will be
in equilibrium in solution
of mannose 6-phosphate.
Similarly, for
fructose 6-phosphate,
we can write its linear form.
Notice, fructose 6-phosphate
has a carbon too,
it's a hemiketal functionality.
This carbon is attached to
both a hydroxyl and an oxygen.
So that will open
up to form a ketone.
All right, this is our fructose
6-phosphate in a linear form.
And notice at 2 position,
we have the ketone.
Now, it would be a good
idea at this point to number
the carbons to see
what do we need
to do, going from
this linear form
of mannose 6-phosphate to
this linear form of fructose
6-phosphate.
So here we have carbons
6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
And we have carbons
And if we contrast
the two structures,
we notice that carbons
from 3 to 6 in both cases
are, in fact, the same.
And we even have
the hydroxyls in
the right stereochemical
orientation,
in the right stereochemistry.
And all we need to do is
move the carbonyl group
from the 1 position
here in mannose
6-phosphate to the 2 position
in the fructose 6-phosphate.
So this transformation
can be accomplished
by an intermediate, which
you have seen already
in glycolysis, the intermediate
that allows to go from glucose
6-phosphate into fructose
6-phosphate, which
is a cis-enediol.
So it's essentially enolization
with the hydrogen on carbon 2.
So if we were to
form the enol here,
which, as you know from
the carbonyl video,
so a base could deprotonate
and allow the electrons
to move and form another
hydroxyl on the 1 position.
Because this is a
cis-enediol, the two hydroxyl
are going to end up on the
same side of the double bond.
Once again, let's
number our carbons.
4, 3, 2, 1.
And this is our cis-enediol.
So we have two hydroxyls.
They're both attached
to a double bond.
And cis means they're both on
the same side of the molecule.
And this allows the
enzyme to basically
switch back and forth between
which one of these hydroxyl
becomes the carbonyl.
If we go backwards, we have
the carbonyl at the 1 position.
However, if we go forward,
we can move the carbonyl
on the 2 position.
So that's just the reverse
of the enolization reaction
in which we will
deprotonate this hydroxyl
and reprotonate at carbon
1 to take us forward
to generate the
2-keto group, which
is fructose 6-phosphate
in the linear form.
Now from here, in
the very last step,
we just need to close the ring.
So that's just a
hemiketal formation.
We have a base deprotonated
hydroxyl at position 5.
And this will attack the ketone
to form the hemiketal group
that we see in
fructose 6-phosphate.
So now this is basically
the curved arrow mechanism
from going from
mannose 6-phosphate
to fructose 6-phosphate.
Now, some key points
to notice here
is that this enolization
reaction where the base removes
this alpha hydrogen would
not have been possible
in the cyclic structures.
If you look here, this
hydrogen, the PKA is about 30.
Now, once we form the
linear structure here,
the PKA of this hydrogen,
now it's about 18.
So that's like 12 order
of magnitude more acidic,
and that allows the reaction
to for this cis-enediol,
which allows the formation
of the fructose 6-phosphate.
So the take home message here
is that opening and closing
the ring of the sugars allows
a lot of interesting chemistry
to happen.
Part three of this question
asks us to comment on
why, when going from
mannose to fructose,
we have to go
through the mannose
6-phosphate intermediate.
Now, this turns out to
be a very common motif
in carbohydrate
chemistry, because adding
a phosphate group is a way of
regulation of which product
is being formed.
Taking a closer look
at our transformation,
we see that if we didn't have
the phosphate group at the 6
position, this hydroxyl
would be available
and could potentially
be involved
in forming cyclic forms.
As we recall our discussion
on fructose, whenever
we have a 6-hydroxyl
available, the fructose
can form the fructopyranose
form in addition
to the fructofuranose form.
So by blocking this
position with a phosphate,
we're limiting the reaction
to produce only one product,
namely the fructofuranose.
Additionally, adding a
phosphate group to a sugar
imparts a negative
charge, and that
allows the sugar to be
trapped inside the cell
and allows metabolism to
occur much more efficiently.
This is something
that you've already
encountered in glycolysis, where
glucose, in the first step,
is first converted to
glucose 6-phosphate.